それでは4回目ですね
えっと まあ今日のテーマというのは単純なことで
道徳は知恵のわさびで
不道徳は無知の働きということである倫理学的見方という
で 英語で書いてるのはこの知恵っていうのは
この道徳の根源って何でしたっけ
道徳の家はまあ知恵ですけど
ずっとそれ攻撃されてるんですね
無知から まあ自分の家は
まあ自分の国は外からかなり攻撃されてるのかということで
じゃあ続けていきます
で 訳の例語 人の心は悪に支配されていると言っても過言ではありません
人といったっても全ての生命
前は説明したと思います
で 私たちの心っていうのも
悪にいわゆる不道徳に支配されているんです
善を行いたいという気持ちはあるが
素直に実行しない  どんな人でも
まあ良いことしたいなという気持ちだけはありますけど
誰も真剣に実行しようということはないんです
これがもう心の法則なんですよ
嘘言ってはいけないなとは知ってますが
本気じゃないんですよ
自分のことになってくると
まあすぐつい嘘を言ってしまったりする
だから道徳についてなかなか本気になれないっていうところは
全ての生命にあるんです
他人の悪行為 その結果を見ているから善に憧れますが
なぜ簡単に善人にならないのか
そこで面白いことは 私たちは良いことをした方がいいなと思っているのは
人のことを見る時なんですよ
人が嘘を言って自分を騙したり
悪いことをしたりすると
これはいけませんと思っちゃうんです
それも前の講義ですごく説明しました
自分のことになってくると全然別に悪いと思わないんです
だから 他人が人を殺したり
嘘をついたり 暴力を振るったりしちゃうと
それ見てなんて恐ろしいことか
なんて悪いことですかと
そこで気づくんです それでなんとなく
やっぱり私もやってはいけないんだと思っちゃいますが
それほど本気にはならない
もしそう思うならば 全ての人類が善人ですよ
人の悪を見た途端 あ これは私ならやりませんよと決めちゃえば
もう簡単にみんな良い人間なんですけど
全然そうなりませんね
この問題の心理的根底を分析してみましょうと
なんでそうならないのかという
この心理的な心の中に何か問題があるんですよ
で 我々はなんでそんなにいいことをしたいんだけど
なんでできないのかと
なんでその気にならないのかっていうことは
我々の心の中で何かちょっと問題があるんです
その問題を今日分析したいと思います
難しくなるか簡単になるかわかりませんだけど
すぐにできます そこではオリジンオブイービルということ
どのように悪が罪が現れたのかという
Y
e kecha akusara dhamma sabbe te avijja mulaka avijja samosar
ana avijja samuggahata
sabbe te  samuggahata gacchanti
これサングッチャニカーエのテキストにある一行なんです
まあ釈尊の言葉です まあ不善というべきもののすべて
不善 悪というならば その一切は無明を根底にしているんだと akusala
mulaka 無明があって
無明から不善 一切の不善が現れてくるんだと avijja
samosarana
この無明でこれをまとめて
もう全部悪いことをやらせているんですよ
無明に無明を中心とする
無明から生じる 無明 パーリ語の言葉avijjaなんですね avijja
というものがあります
無明というものが心にありまして
そこから一切の悪が発生しているんだと
それが origin なんですね
その時点では仏教は全然異論もなし
断定的に無明であるとしているのです
それはブッダの言葉で
まあそれがそんなに説明する必要はないんです
まあすぐに行きます それから無明アヴィッジャっていうのはどういうものかと
まあゆっくり考えましょう
無知 無明 まあどちらも同義語なんですね
無知と言っても無明と言ってもね
それは悪の根源ですね
で これはもう心に根付いている状態ですから
一切の生命に共通なのです
この心にもう根付いている
心といえばもう無明でできているんですよ
だからどんな生命にも心があるんだから
もう言うまでもなく無明があるんです
だから仏教はこの人間人間というふうに喋れないということも覚えておいてください
一切の生命 高次元の生命から一番低次元の生命まで
我々知ってる生命も知らない生命も何にもいいんだから
一切の生命 衆生ということを仏教の考え方で使う言葉なんですね
ただ 人間論を語っているわけでもないんです
人間論ですけど その法則はすべての生命に当てはめるんです
だから生命であるならば
ミミズであってもミミズにも心があるんですよ
生きているんだから 無明があるんですよ
明らかに 神とか何とか言ってるものにも
やっぱり心があるんだから
生命と言うでしょう だったら無明があるんです
誰でも同じなんです いつ無明は現れたのですか？次の問題は
これややこしい 無明がいつ現れたんですかと
仏教ではこれは答えが存在しない質問としますね
仏教ではこれは答えがない
答えが存在しない質問です
いつ現れたのかと聞いても答えがないんです
答えがないんだったら
まあもう答えようがないんです
生命は無明があるからこそ輪廻転生している
そこで生命がいるとすると無明があるんですよ
だからもう答えがなくなっちゃうんですね
どういうことかというと
この 例えば一切生命がない時点というのはね
心がない時点でしょうに
それだったら認識も何もないでしょうに
例えば石二つ同士で何のコンタクトも何の関係もないでしょう
石二つだったらお互いにいるともいないとも何もわからない
生き物 じゃないんです
だから哲学やら宗教やら何でも生命のことを言ってるでしょう
地理学物理学以外の 生命のことを言ってるんだから
生命ができた時点でもう心があってもう無明があるんです
だからいつ我々かったかっていうことはもう全然言いすらえんです
まだ説明入ると思いますけどね
輪廻は不死なるものだとしているのです
輪廻っていうのは この不死というのはこのはじめない
だから輪廻というんです
生命はいつ誕生したのかということに
仏教ははじめがありませんと言うんです
なんでそう言うのかって
例えば地球上の生き物だけ生命だというと始めがあるんですよ
地球という物体があります
その物体がいつ我々れたかというふうに知られるし
それだったらその物体の中でいつ生命が誕生したのかということは言えるんです
しかし 仏教は生命というと
この地球上の存在に限るということではないんだから
もう神々も生命でしょうし
幽霊も化け物もみんな生命なんです
いるかいないか それは別として
まあいるとするならば
すべて生命なんです だったら地球とは関係ないんです
そういうことだから あの不死という言葉を使うんです
初めはない は
い それにもお釈迦様の言葉で Anattā go yaṃ, bhikkhu, yaṃ saṃsāro, uppāko ti na tañhājeti;
avijjā nīvaraṇā naṃ sattānaṃ taṇhāsanyojanā naṃ sandāvattaṃ saṃsaratā'ti.
これも何回何回も繰り返して出てくる言葉なんです
ただ 1箇所にあるわけじゃなくて
こちらで引用する単語っていうのはほとんどの経典でも出ているもので
だから明らかにブッダの言葉っていうことはものすごい確かなところなんです
たった 1箇所で 1行だけであったら
あれ これは本当かなという疑問が出せますけど
これは 100回も 200回も出てくると
これはまあ確かな言葉になるんです
比丘たちよ この輪廻の始点は不死了である
無明に覆われて 渇愛に束縛されて
転生して彷徨っている衆生の始点というものは見当たりません
終点は考えられますよ
解脱すれば終点だから
始点はもう不死了考えられません
過去をさかのぼるとエンドレス
これ単純ですよ 理解するのは
例えば今私には精神的なエネルギーがありますね
物質は地球からもらったもの
それは明らかなんです
しかし 精神も地球からもらったわけじゃないんです
命も これ エネルギーっていうのは突然現れることは絶対ありえないと仏教はするんですよ
何も原因なく何か現れるというのはおかしいんだ
ありえない 何の原因もなく何か現れるんだったら
突然我々の頭の上から角でも生えてくる可能性ありますよ
原因いらないんだから
夜寝たところで朝起きると翼がついてる可能性もありますよ
でもそんなことは絶対ありえないでしょう
なぜかというと 因果法則だから
夜寝たんだけど 朝からすごく体がだるくて
もう足腰が痛いということはありえますよ
それは原因があるんですよ
なかなか寝不足なかったんだから
全然疲れが取れてないとかね
それぐらいのことはありえます
だからだいたいは次に何が起こるのかっていうことは
因果法則の中で 我々にはそれなりに推測はできます
例えばあと 5年経ったら
我々みんな結構もう老けて老化していると
これはもう因果法則でありえることです
しかし  5年経ったところで
突然 20歳若返っているっていうことは
これはもうありえない話
だから 原因なし 突然現れるという
な仏教は全くのいい加減なことである
否定するんです そういうことだから
今私に精神的なエネルギーがあります
この精神的なエネルギーが何もないところで生まれたんだと言うならば
いきなり植物の人間になってしまう可能性もありますよ
いきなり家でオシャレとして置いている置物は
突然命を入り込んじゃって喋り出す可能性もありますよ
それっていうのはもうバカバカしくてありえないでしょう
置物の猫は突然命が入ってきて
普通の生きている猫になったとかね
そんなのはありえない
ですから 今私にある精神というのは
過去に何か原因があって現れたもの
だから精神的なエネルギーは作り出すのも当然精神的なエネルギー
鉄を持って何を作っても鉄製物で物でしょ
決して水でできたものにはなりませんね
だから私に過去というのがあったということは
この推測でも考えられます
別に私は過去で人間でいたっていう話じゃないんです
こちらで生まれる前に
精神として何かの形の過去があった
ということは そちらでも生命でいたっていうことなんですよ
そちらで生命でいたっていうことは
その以前 また生命でいたっていうことなんです
ということは もっと以前
また生命でいたっていうことで
これをどう考えたってのはじめはなしなんです
これ初めがないってことをお釈迦様はあらゆるたとえ話で説明してますよ
初めなしということよりも
どれほど長いかと で 一つの今たくさんありますよ
もうあまりたくさんありすぎて
もうもうそう簡単に思い出せませんだけど
一つはこの地球の全部土を
このあの弁当に付いてる梅干しありますね
あの小さな梅干し あれぐらいの大きさに
なんかインドのある植物のことなんですけど
あのコーラッキーというあのコーラッキーの種で
まあもうこれぐらい小さいものなんです
でっかいものじゃないんです
小さな 種 あの普通 あのコンビニの弁当に付いている梅干しぐらいと思ってください
指でこうやって触れますからね
地球のすべての土をそれぐらい
段にしてある人が一個一個
これが私の母 これが私の父とかね
もう数えて入れても 自分の過去の母父の数がもっと多いんだよ
あの土が終わっちゃいますよ
そういうたとえでしか
この当時の人々には理解できないんです
それでも理解していたかどうかはわかりませんだけど
この現代数学は発展しているんですけど
この無数ということはなかなか理解できるものじゃないんです
無数と無限というのは
我々は理解しないで ただこのシンボルでわかったような気がするだけ
体験経験はできない 難しい
[背景音楽]もう一つの例は
このインドにある全部植物をとって
ある人がこの指の 2つ節 2つぐらいの大きさに切るんだと切ってまた数えてみるんだ
これは私の過去とこれはもっと前の過去やと数えたっても
あのスティックがありますよ
同じ人で同じ人が母にして
過去で泣いた涙 母が亡くなると悲しいでしょう
一般的には悲しいんですけどね
皆さんはどうかわかりませんだけど
母が亡くなると悲しいんですよ
いくら頑張っても涙が来るんです
この大海の海より多いんだ
涙の量をまとめてみたってこと
それは一人の人のために泣いた涙なんです
それぐらいあなた方は過去で輪廻転生したんだよ
あなた方は味わってきた苦しみっていうのは
もう想像を絶するものじゃないんだという風にお釈迦様がこのずっとたくさん経典の中でも説明してあるんです
だから仏教の時間 次元というのは
このある人のこの地球のことを喋っているわけじゃないんです
宇宙スケールで全て喋ってます
仏教の人で見れば このビッグバンなんかはもうすごく常識的な当たり前の話で
そんなのはもう数えられないほど起きるんだよと言ってるんだからね
そういうことだから 過去を見られる能力があったお釈迦様にも
それは見当たりません
ということになっています
で また始めなければいいねっていうこと
無明は知らないという意味なので
知らないという状態は根本的です
これよく理解してください
なぜ無明に始まりがないのかというと
知らないということは根本的なんですよ
我々は知るためには努力しなくちゃいけない
生まれた赤ちゃんが知らないということは当たり前
それからいろんなことを知るようになっていくんですよ
だから 知ることは努力の結果なんです
知らないことは普通の状態なんです
生まれてきた赤ちゃんが何も知らない
そこで乳母そうなくちゃっていうことは習う
それから物を掴むことやら笑ってあげることやら
いろんなことをどんどんどんどん知るという方向へ行くんですよ
我々はもう生まれたまんまで置いておけば
何も知らないでしょう
歩くことももしかすると知らないし
喋るところじゃなくて
歩くことにしたっても
知らない状態からどんどん知る状態になって歩けるんですよ
だから知らないところから知るところへ進むのは普通です
ですから 無明はいつ始めたを始めたのかと聞く質問自体がおかしいんです
無明はいつ始めたのかというと
無明という何かあって
それがいつ現れたのかということなんです
何かあるならば いつという質問は OK です
例えばこの蛍光灯はいつつけたのかという質問はぴったし正しいんですよ
なぜならば今蛍光灯があるんだからなんです
無明ということは 何か巨大なものがあるというではなくて
基本的な状態なんです
では 生まれる赤ちゃんは何かすごいことを持って生まれるんですかね
何も持ってないんです
それ以上に落ちているんです
あのカントですか 誰でしたか
あのタブーラサーという単語を使っちゃったんですけどね
最初 あの最初は何もないんだと
心に真っ白や それからいろんな情報を刻んでいく
この真っ白い この誰か
あまり思い出せませんだけど
最初は心は真っ白やっていう状態が無明なんです
知らないって意味だから
だから仏教に聞いても無明はいつ始めたのかということを笑っちゃいます
そんな質問成り立たないんだと
根本状態ですから それであの生生常常なんとか論でヴィスッディマグガというテキストで
これは結構扱って説明しようとしてるんです
あの無明には始めはない
無明は根本原人であるとするならば始めなんかというのは
あんまりその説明はちょっとあの
ちょっと違いますけどね
いつから知らなくなった
というのはあまり賢い質問ではありません
いつから知るようになったかということはわかりますよ
意味は いつがいつから知らなくなったのかといったって
何でしょうかね 質問ではないんです
これ 例えて言ってみると
赤ちゃんにいつから言葉を喋れなくなったと聞くことと同じなんですよ
赤ちゃん言葉喋れないでしょ
赤ちゃんに聞く 君 いつから喋れなくなったんですか？いつからってわけじゃないでしょうに
赤ちゃんは言葉を喋れない
ただそれだけ 初めから
それから言葉を喋れるように知る世界に進む
そうすると聞けます この赤ちゃんがいつから言葉を言い出しましたかと
言うと赤ちゃんが覚えてないんだから
母親でもまあもう一歳になってくると喋り出したとかね
もうなんとか言うでしょう
だから無明には始めはなしっていうのはもうそういうわけです
それで初めっていうことは随分気になって考える人々もいます
他宗教哲学では初めを考えているように見える
他の宗教哲学を調べると
みんな初めっていう考え方にかなりこだわっています
これは仏教はもう完全にダメだと言ってますけど
永遠不滅の魂があるとする宗教では
魂は本来全知で不滅だとする
あるまあ 一つの宗教ではなくても
一般的な宗教では この永遠不滅の魂があると
生命には まあヨーロッパになってくると人間に輪になっちゃうし
インドの宗教になってくると生命にはってなっちゃうんですね
魂があるんだ これが初めからあると
それがまた何でしたっけ？全知全能
全知である 全能というより不滅
個我は汚れているから全知でもないし
死も経験する それで個我は自分の魂になってくると全知じゃないね
もうこの講義でも聞いたってわからないでしょう
全知だったらすぐわかるのに
結果苦労しないとわからないんですね
だから我々は全知じゃないんですね
それだけじゃなくて 私たちは死を経験する
それを個が死を経験するんですけど
この本来の我は死なないんだ
という風に宗教で言う
修行によって元の状態に戻ることを推薦する
それで修業しなさいよと
今個我でしょうと この心の汚れを落として元に戻りなさいよという風に修行を推薦するんです
しかし 全知から小知になったので
見えないが続けてる 何かが消されてるんですね
まあ一応我々はその宗教の方々の考え方は正しいと思うならば
論理的には全知状態にいて小知状態になってしまった
心が汚れちゃった これよく覚えてほしいんです
全知状態から小知状態になってしまった
魂 全知から小知になったので
再び全知になってもまた小知になることは避けられないんですよ
これがその他宗教で考えてないポイントなんですよ
無明はって 例えば宗教の名前を挙げて言うならば
まあヒンドゥー教なんかは
バラモン教なんかはもう梵我という宇宙全体的に一つの魂があって
それが全知全能でというんですね
そこが分解して個が現れて輪廻転生しているんだと
自分の行為に 業によって
だから苦しんでるんだ
だから汝は苦しんでる
汝は個我であるから なぜ個我ですかというと
汝には智慧がないんだ
心が汚れてるんだと だから横柄にもやりやがっちゃって
心を綺麗にしなさいよと
そうすると梵が一如という状態になるんだ
もしそれはそうだとするならば
では我々もやっと修行して
まあよくやっている方々っていうのはもう盗みたくさんするんです
悟った人っていうのはもうもうゼロですけど
まあとにかくもうやっと修行して悟ったとしましょう
梵が一如を経験したとしましょう
そうするとあの元の梵我に戻るでしょう
でもあいつが分解して
個が作っちゃった だから安心できない
次にあることは決まってる
個我になること だから全我か個我になるならば
個我は頑張って全我になる
なったところでまた落とされます
また落とされないという理由は何一つ成り立たないです
だからお釈迦様はこれはもう最終解脱でも悟りでもないと
ただのエリファスや だからエリファスを始めたのは
この初めというものを考え出しましたからね
彼らの考え方は まあ頭はいいかもしれませんだけど
考え方がよく正しくないんだ
で 皆本来如来である 仏である
覚者であったという場合も論理は同じ
それは大乗仏教の考え方なんですね
まあ大乗仏教といってもヒンドゥー教
全くヒンドゥー教なんです
ただ 訳柄は違う ブッダやら菩薩やらまあ出てくるだけで
全部ヒンドゥー教なんです
ですから このヒンドゥー教の考え方
梵が一如っていうのはものすごく違和感なく
それはその通りだと認めるんです
でも みんな知らないのは
もともと本来如来であった我々は今くだらない凡夫でしょう
修行して悟ったっても何の意味もないんですよ
また落とされますから
大日如来のところに行っても
法身ブッダになっても何の意味もないんです
またくたびれる だって元々法身であった
法身と言うんですよ 法の体と書きますけどね
これがこの宇宙全体的な魂のこと
大乗仏教になってくると訳柄変わりますから
法身ブッダになるんです
梵我にはなりません まあそれだけのことで
そんなことでも初め大日如来がね
永遠不滅にいて その人が現象世界を作ったならばね
我々踏ん張って上へ上がっても
また蹴っ飛ばされますよ
何の意味もなくなっちゃうんです
ヒンドゥー教 ジャイナ教
大乗仏教などは以上のカテゴリに入ります
はい 初めは全知全能の完全な神がいて
生命を創造したという一神教もあります
一神教も一つではなくてたくさんあります
ユダヤ教 キリスト教 イスラム教一神教ですですね
インドにもそういう一神教的な宗派があったんですけど
なんとなくもう消えつつもあるし
現れつつもあるし 今一般的なこのそれほどこの知識人ではない一般のインドの方々は
どちらかというと一神教宗派なんです
ヒンドゥー教の方 完全たる創造主も作られたものも完全です
当たり前ですね 完全な人は欠陥なものを作らないんだからね
しかし 生命人間は罪に汚れているから罪に始点があるのです
それでこういう考え方
初めは神が作ったんだと
生命 神が完全だから作ったものは完全です
神が作った命は完全な命
しかし 今ちょっと見ると人間が完全じゃないんです
罪があるんです 人間が不完全で死たるものなんです
死すべきものなんです
だから完全な人間に何か欠陥が入ったんですよ
そうなると欠陥がいつ入ったのかと正しく問います
初めはなかったんですけど
いつ現れたのかと それはキリスト教を調べてみると
はっきりとこの罪が現れた時点を書いているんです
この時点に罪が現れた
その前は罪がなかった
動物も人間もみんな同じことを喋って
ずいぶん仲良くしていたと
死ぬということはなかった
だから初めは神様が完全に作っちゃったんですけど
もう途中でちょっとこけてしまったという
これは神の創造ミスであって
だからこれは私の批判で
仏教的な批判で 途中で人間が汚れたならば
これは神のミスなんです
完全な人がそんなことぐらい予測せてほしいです
本人は処理しない限り
本人というのは神様が処理しない限り
人間にはどうすることもできない
だから心汚れてる罪を犯してる人間には全く無気力で何もできませんよと
神様がやってくれないと
彼が作ったんだから それは現代でイスラム教とユダヤ教とキリスト教ではその理屈で
徹しています しかし 全知全能と創造ミスは一致しない話
全知全能という考え方と設計ミスというかね
創造ミスっていうのは馬鹿げた話なんですよ
でも堂々と言ってるんです
一回神様がこれ失敗しまとって
ノアの方舟を作ってね
全部潰しちゃったんですけど
欠陥品を その時もまた神様がミスを犯しちゃうんですよ
あの欠陥品の一部を参考にとっちゃったんだと
なんてバカだ 全部綺麗さっぱり潰して
また新しく作った方が良かったのに
また欠陥品から参考出た
いらんの 初め無から作ったのに
だからもうすごいこのもう単純論理ですよ
こんなの そういう意味です
これ仏教の立場 存在は因縁により成り立たせので
それに変化して存在というのは因縁によって成り立って変化していくもの
したがって初めは成り立たない
このバカな考え方だと
初め 始点考えても それも因縁によって成り立ったんだから
因縁はもっと先にあるんですよ
だから今何かあるのは先に何かあったんだからなんです
それで先に何かあったのはもっと先にまた何かあったんだからなんです
だったら初めから成り立たない
因縁で考えましょう 因果法則に則って考えなさい
ある日突然も無縁も矛盾ですと
ある日突然というのはすごい俗っぽい言葉で
これは哲学的な言葉で
まあ突然偶然と我々一般的に使ってますね
これはありえないんです
突然偶然というのは それから無縁
何も縁がなく何か現れるということもありえないんです
パーリ経典では Adicca samuppanna ahetu appaccayaという単語でそれを表しています
ある日突然何か現れるんだったら
これおっかないんですよ
もう一寸先もわからなくなっちゃいます
それで因果法則によって
例えば北朝鮮が日本に爆弾を落とすとすると
ある日突然 今日夜12時には絶対落としませんよ
なぜですか それにも原因はちゃんと熟していないと
北朝鮮もそれなりに日本に対してすごい怒り憎しみを持って抱いて
それからいろんな準備をして
いろんな情報を集めて
で 最終的に決断を出さなくちゃいけないでしょう
そこまでそちらでやっていると
日本もそれを大体大体ではなくて
ほぼ知っている 向こうから攻撃してくるかもしれませんよと
ほぼ知っていて こちらもそれなりに対応策を練る
それで爆弾が落ちても
誰もそんなにびっくりはしない
あ やったということ だから何もある日突然起こるっていうことはありえないんです
例えば皆さんも太陽は破壊すると知ってるでしょ？地球が破壊するっていうことは知ってるでしょう
では 明日太陽爆破すると思いますか？絶対ありえないんですよ
太陽が爆破してしまうならば
随分なんの千年2000年前からのその太陽がいろいろ不安定になって
結構フレアが出たり いろんなこと起きたりして
それでも爆破するんですよ
だから因果法則なんです
何でも だから我々は安全というかね
それなりに安心して生きていられます
ある日突然何か起こるといえば
自分の子供が朝見るともう犬になってるとかね
犬を買って外で犬小屋で鎖で縛っておいたんですけど
朝餌をあげようとしたら赤ちゃんになっているんだとかね
そんなのはありえないでしょう
だからある日突然と無縁っていうのはもうあまりにもバカバカらしいんです
一切は因縁によるという立場は
仏教はもう断言する もしこれが正しければ
次にどうなるかは想像することも推測することもできません
だからこれはありえないんです
特にこの神様のことを取り出す方々はこのある日突然という概念をとっています
論理は全然成り立たない
はい で アヴィッジャーについてまた説明続きます
この初めの視点を考えるなかれというところで
ブッダが言うのは こんなのばかばかしいということで
アヴィッジャーについて
アヴィッジャーの初め方
真理を知らない状態はアヴィッジャーです
真理とは本当の状態 ありのままの事実ですから
それは一つであって複数にはなれません
真理といえば本当の状態だから
いくつかあるはずがない
例えば地球の形に対する真理は丸いということでしょ
形だったらこれに複数の意見がないんです
丸いんですけど サッカーボールと同じやと
あるいはラグビーボールとラグビーボールはちょっと違いますからね
似ているやとかね そういう風にはなりませんね
事実は初めから知っているものではなく
これから観察して発見するものです
我々はすべて初めから知っているわけじゃないでしょうに
我々人間の社会見ても
私たちは初めは何も知らなかったでしょうに
動物でいた石器時代では
でもそれからじわじわじわじわといろんなものを知るようになったんです
だから知らない状態はもう基本的な状態で
そこから知る世界に行かなくちゃいけない
ブッダの教えを真理したっても
知らないのは当たり前です
それから勉強して研究して
いろいろ試してみて 知っていかなくちゃいかないんです
知らないのは当たり前ということはないです
はい いろいろなものが入っちゃうんですね
俺は入れてないんですけど
カタマンチャ ビッケーアヴィッチャー
あれははてななんです
汚い だからある日突然悪口言ってるのはそれってある日突然そういう結果ということではなくて
それにも原因がありますよ
おそらく私が使ったフォントをこのコンピューターで入れ替えているんです
大体フォント ヤンコービッケー
ドゥッケーアンニャーナ
ドゥッカサンデーアニャーナ
ドゥッカニローデーアニャーナ
ドゥッカニローデガーミニア
パティパダヤンニャーナ
アヤムムッチャティビッケーアヴィッジャ
無明って何でしょうかと
苦を知らないこと 苦の原因を知らないこと
苦の滅を知らないこと
苦を滅する方法を知らないことです
これは無明と言います
明確に提言する だからどんな宗派の仏教の宗派の人にも自分勝手にこうではないか
ああではないかということはできない
この苦って何でしょうかね
これは四聖諦と言っているブッダの真理の四つなんです
それが誰でも知りませんよとお釈迦様はよく教えています
これから頑張ってください
発見できますよ ただ 地球が丸いということは誰も知らないでしょう
あらゆる研究して それ結果として知るんです
それで苦っていうのは
この存在に対するお釈迦様のこの言葉なんです
存在は苦であると 生きるということは
苦っていうのは苦しいという意味というよりも
すごくこの でしょうかね
どうしても納得いかない
生きるというところ 満足できない
なんかどこかで気に入らない
それずっと続くんですよ
それで楽をしようと思っちゃうと
たくさん苦しみ その場合
普通の苦しみを味わえなくなってくる
例えばいっぱい金があって楽をしたいなと思ったら
寝ないで仕事をしなくちゃいけない
1 日 3時間しか寝る暇なくなっちゃうんです
1 日 3時間しか寝てない人々には金がいっぱいあるんですよ
だからあったって何のためかと
そういうことで納得いかないんですよ
何があっても子供が生まれても楽しいんだけど
これから大変で 自分の思う通りには全くいかない
だからすごく不満を感じちゃうんです
それから我々はまだまだやりたいこといっぱいあるにも関わらず
年取って 例えば若い時
十分やりたいことをやってないんですよ
だから若い時やったことをまだやりたいという気持ちがあるんです
ということは その時も納得いっていなかったんです
そういう命だよ それがすごいわかりやすい説明で
結構難しいんですけどね
それからなんで納得いかないのかという原因もあります
それは渇愛といってね
まあ満足してやるぞという期待なんです
ありえないんです 生の中で満足するっていうことは
生きていることで満足できるっていうことはありえないんです
生きていることが不満なものだから
しかし 我々はそれに構わず
とにかく納得してやるぞと
満足してやるぞと踏ん張っちゃうんです
だったらずっと苦しみが続いちゃうんです
それが2番目  3番目はこの
この渇愛を捨てちゃえばいい
放っておけば全然 終わりなんです
簡単ですけど 一切の期待も希望も
もう渇愛という なんとかやるぞという気持ち
全部捨てる 一点簡単に聞こえますけど
結構難しいんですよ やっぱり何もしないぞと
何も期待しないぞと 放っちゃうと楽そうに見えますね
でもこれ難しいんで 期待するんですよ
その方法があるんですよ
八正道という その八正道を実践しない限りは
これできるものじゃないんです
だから この 4つの真理
苦と この原因と 苦をなくすことと
苦をなくす方法という
それが知らない限りは無明であると
そんなに珍しいことではないんですよ
無明というのは 我々の普通の状態を言ってるんです
この 4つ言ったら無明がないんですよ
悟ってるんです  [背景音楽]一切の現象は無常
苦 無我であるが これまた別な立ち場で説明なんです
すべての物事は無常ですよ
苦ですよ その場合は苦っていうのはこの空しいという
無我ですよ 実体はない
が 無知によって衆生は常住楽がだと思う
我々にはこの無常ということが全然さっぱりわからないんです
これすっごいものすごい難しいポイントなんです
無常はわからないんですよ
だから皆さん無常ぐらいわかってるぞという気分でしょう
日本も結構無常は文学にもなってるんだよとかね
違うんです それを無常わかるとすぐ覚り悟りますよとおっしゃってるんだからね
わかってないことは明らかなんです
無常と言ったらもうたちまちそれで悟り
じゃあ我々知ってる無常ってのは無常じゃないんですよ
あれは自分の気分次第で
無常にしたり そうでないものにしたり
例えば花が枯れるということは当たり前に知ってるけど
しかし花はどうすれば長持ちするのか
そればっかり考えてるんです
枯れるもんだと知ってるんだって
そんな馬鹿なこと考えないでしょう
それいい加減なんですよ
そこで私たち知ってる無常はこういう無常なんだ
花がもう散る ものは壊れるという場合はすごい誤解があるんです
自分が変わらない 変わらない自分が花を見たところで花が散ってしまう
なんて儚いことだとその時歌ったりもします
あれなどは心理でもなんでもないです
だからこれが無常だというために
言う人が 観察する人が常という立場でいないとできないんです
我々はその足かせに引っ張られてるんです
例えば犬の寿命って短いでしょ
よく知ってるでしょ なんでしょう
犬は 15年だから 我々もっと長い生きしますから知ってるんです
しかし ガラパゴスにいるゾウガメの寿命は知らない
でしょうね 人間より寿命は数倍も長いです
だから何代も何代も行かない限りは計算できない
印入れておいて その科学者たちが死んじゃって
次の世代に行って 次の世代も次の世代も
まだ知らないんですよ
結構長生きしてる それで次
この逆さまの知識はすべての罪を引き起こすのです
この無常でないんだからですよ
我々は罪を犯すのは 例えば銀行強盗したいと思っちゃう
自分が安全だと 長生きできるんだということを知ってるんだから
銀行強盗するんです もし自分がもう一時間もたたんうちに死ぬかもしれませんとわかったら
やめますよ 人に何か言われたら怒る
自分がいるんだ 変わらないんだっていうことで怒るんです
相手でもずっとその調子でいるんだと
すごい錯覚なんですけど
人は怒ったっていう瞬間だけですけど
それは別な気持ちなんですけど
我々はその人は変わらない
無常ではありません だからずっと恨んでやると
相手がずっと変わってるのに
こっちは恨んでる それで恨みはどんどん変わるんですよ
あの 初めぶちぶされた怒りにふさわしい恨みじゃないんで
どんどんそれも大きくなっちゃう
人によってへったりもします
この逆さまな思考が罪の原因なんですね
ひよこさん 原因ではなくて
罪を犯すとき 人は無知に支配されている
そこでどんな罪を犯すときでも
この無知に支配されているんです
なぜ無常は知らないんだから罪を犯すでしょう
もう無知なんです 知らないってこと
怒り 憎しみ 欲 怠け 恥し-
恥入らない  恥じらないなどなどの感情は無知無明によって現れるものです
すべてのどんな罪でも無知から現れます
はい 次に行きましょう
それから不道徳の仕組み
無明があるから まず自分がいる
存在すると思う すべて無常でしょう
だからいるということはなりたたないんですよ
でも我々 私がいると思っている
続いて他人も他のものも実体としてある
存在すると思う 次に 体に心に快楽を与える対象を我がものにしたくなる
自分がいるんだから 自分のものにしたいんですね
快楽を与えてくれるもの
これは欲という執着なんです
体に心に不快感を与えるものを放したくなる
これは怒りという執着なんです
全部私がいるんだというあの逆さま思考から出てくる
はい 次 この二つの感情の流れが軌道に乗ってない時
痴だけが働き出す 痴っていうのは無知ってこと
これは痴という執着なんです
それで三種類の執着があるんです
執着っていうのはなかなかなくならない
消えないという意味なんです
三種類です 欲か怒りか痴か
怠け 眠気 混乱 疑い 無気力
落ち込み うつなどが現れてくる
この無知に支配されちゃうとそんなものになっちゃうんですね
欲と怒りだったら結構活発ですよ
ものすごい活発です 無知に支配されると活発でなくなっちゃうんです
次のポイント 変わらない私がいる
変わらない他がい パーリ語でアッチャッタ・バヒッタなんですね
という前提があるからこそ
不道徳的な生き方になる
罪を犯す 私がいると言ったら当然他がいるということになる
それでも私を守るために他を使ったり壊したりという生き方をしているんです
愛し 愛したり憎しんだり
そういう生き方になる
それは初めから私がいるというあの無明なんですよ
問題です  BGMあるところで早く進みましょう
私がいるというのは決まっているとみんな思っています
イダ・ピッティヴェ・アッサ・タヴァ・プトゥッジャノ
ルーパン・アッタ・トー・サマナ・パッサティ
ルーパワンタン・ワ・アッターナ
アッタニ・ワ・ルーパン
ルーパス・ニン・ワ・アッターナ
これ長い文章をちょっと切っちゃったんです
長い文章はヨティドル・ダッサラ・ブッジャノ
サップル・セダン・マッサ・アヴィニート
アリヤ・ダンマ・サコーイド
と言って 真理を学んでない普通の人は色っていうのはもう一般的にそういう言葉使ってるんだから体なんですね
体が我と思う我 魂ですね
我にも体があるとする
魂にも体があるとする
あれは我に体が入っていると思う
または体の中に我があると思う
なんかちょっとわかりにくいね
しかし そこで当時インドであったすべての論をまとめているんです
お釈迦様が だから インドの宗教は全部勉強しなくても
仏教経典読んだら そういう人々は何を言ってるかということをニクッと理解できる
仏教を知っている人にとっては
ウパニシャッドやらヴェーダーンタやら何を勉強するのはものすごい簡単単純なの
読むだけで十分です なぜかというと
経典の中で全部分析して
カテゴリにして分けて
明確に批判まで入れちゃってあります
そこでこの体だけじゃなくて
十 ヴェーダナ感覚も それからサンニャーっていうのは想と書きますね
サンカーラは行ですね
ヴィンニャーナは心 心なんですね
そういう 5つがあります
体に 肉体があって感覚があります
それは十と言われる それからあらゆる概念いっぱい持ってますね
頭の中に 青いとか黄色いとかね
美味しいとか不味いとか
そういうシステムは想と書くんですね
サンニャー それから我々はいつでも何かやりたくてやりたくているんです
ストップはならない 体にも心にも
いつでも何かする しないといられないんです
このエネルギーはサンカーラと言われます
ヴィンニャーナっていうのは心のこと
精神という物体と分かれると
残りはヴィンヤーナなんです
その 5つに対して私の我だとみんな思っている
これ分かりやすくするほど下書いてます
体が魂 1 体が魂という立場である
あるいは感覚が魂という立場
あるいは自分持っている概念の世界が魂
あるいは自分の衝動 何かしたくてしたくてたまらん気持ちあるんですね
それが自分の魂 あるいは自分の心そのものが魂ではないかという一つ考え方
2番目は魂の体の形というステップなんです
魂 体じゃなくて受想行識も入ります
で お釈迦様に会ってよく喋ったバラモン人はもう体肉体そのものが魂と思っていた人々のほうがすごく多かったんです
そこで 例えば自分の感覚が自分の魂であるという場合は
この 2番目に入るんですね
3番目は魂の中に体が出来上がる
で 魂があって その魂に合わせて体があって
感覚があって 考え方があって
好き嫌いがあってというふうな考え方
その魂によって合成している
もう一つ 体の中に魂が宿っているという 4つですね
ですから 我に対する一切の思考
哲学はこの 4つの中に入ります
難しくなりましたけど
えーと これはまあ難しくないと私は思っています
なぜならば みんな魂があると思っているんだから
自分の考え方 何やと見れば
その中に入りますよ 四つの中のどちらか
だから 頭からの我は否定している我々にとっては
ちょっと例え話などを言って説明するのは難しいんです
イメージもできない 魂
しかし 仏教以外の方々はみんな我論なんです
魂があると思っている
例えば純仏教論知ってる人々も体が命だと
物質性だと言ってるんですよ
それは 1 なんです だから
無常は言ってるわけじゃないんです
この 4番目 体の中に魂が宿っているっていうのは
もう大体キリスト教でも体の中に宿っている
イスラム教はもっと違う
一緒や 体で魂が構成している
だからイスラム教はものすごい恐ろしいんだから
この憎しみが正しいと教えている宗教だから
人が何か泥棒でもしちゃうと右手を切っちゃう
なんで天国に行ったっても手がないんだよ
そこまで憎しみあるぞ
なんで首を切るのか知ってますか？このテロたちが誘拐した人々
絶対もう地獄に落としてやるよということなんです
間違って天国に行ったっても意味がないんです
首がないんだから だから
いかに憎しみを機能しているのかという
この体の考えがそういう考え方なんです
と言いながら 自爆テロを養成するときは
この肉体は仮のものである
神のために死ねば 体がクタクタ壊れても
完全たる体は向こうでいただけます
特別な席がありますということを言っているんです
で 無茶なんですけど イスラム教の哲学はあまりまとめることはできないんです
世界中の人も禁止します
他の人は読んでもいけない
まあ読めますけどね で
これで頭がイカれているこのイランとかなんとかという連中の解説なんですね
みんなやってる コーランそのものの考え方じゃないんです
コーランそのものではそんなこと言ってないんですけど
読んでもいいんです まあどうせ頭がイカれる病院に行くだけだから
相当に頭が混じります
はい そういうことです
で 別の表現もありますということで
自我に対してこれは私のものと思う
体に対して私の体と思うでしょ
私の考え方 私の楽しみ
私の苦しみって言うでしょ
これが私ですとも言うんです
これは私の我ですと これは現代人はあまり派手に言わないんですけど
たまたま言う 宗教の人々ははっきりそれ言う
特にウパニシャッドの場合は
タットハムシっていうのはもうずっと出てくる言葉なんですね
ウパニシャッドの人には
あれは汝であると で これ３行はお釈迦様がウパニシャッドの哲学者 の人々が言っていることを気にして説かれているところなんです
自分に対して 物事に対して
このように思うからこそ
人が苦しみから脱出できない
不幸の原因になる罪を犯す
では 私の物で考えましょう
私の物と考えちゃうと
それから罪を犯しますよ
私の財布にどうするのかとかね
なんでそれ取るのかとか
で 私のものを奪われたと
それで怒ったりする 私の家に空き巣に入ったと
だからもう苦しみが生まれるんですよ
私のということがあると
だから戦争も引き起こすって
なんだかんだでこの私のという概念なんです
私というものもあれば
敵のものもあるし 他人のものもあるし
でも戦っちゃうんですよ
はい それからもう悪の原因は終わりました
これから善について語ります
で 覚えておいてほしいのは
こういう無明とアヴィッチャーということと
この我っていうね アヴィッチャーと同じこと
そこからこの問題を入れる
で  2種類の善があります
1は相対的対立的善  2は絶対的な善
相対的な善悪を乗り越えた状態
2番  1の説明 一般的な社会で見られる善です
心に根本的に悪の感情があるから
それに対立して 本能に逆らって良い行いをする
それが 1番目なんです
我々の心の中に本能として悪があるんですよ
本当は悪をしたいのです
悪いことしたいんです
誓しないと 本能から出てる感情に逆らうんです
相手殴れという気分が出てくるんだけど
人を殴ってはあかん めったにない
を抑えるんです それが禅なんです
騙してやった方が良かったのに
気持ちはあるんだけど
やっぱりこれは良くない
人を騙しては良くないと自分を戒めている
その戒めが禅なんです
これが一番相対的 善人は本来悪人であることを忘れないでくださいと
だからまあだから善は相対的なんです
例えば我々は人を許すってことをしますね
まあ許してあげましょう
どれぐらいのことはと思って
で ちょっとした悪いことをして
ちょっと気が立って まあ後でまあいいや
なかったことにするし
それ善行為ですよ そこで自分の子供を殺されたですよ
小さな時 学校から帰ってる途中で
もう誰かに殺して もう犯人見つかる
それで親が許してあげた
それも善行為なんです
どちらの方が上ですかね
善行為の力強いんですかね
私にちょっと私が頼んだことをやらなかったんです
誰かが で 私は腹が立ったんです
で またまあいいわと許してあげる
それも善行為 自分の可愛い子供を殺した犯人を許してあげる
それも善行為 同じ許しなんですよ
では結果は同じですかね
どう思いますか どう思いますか
子供のことに大きな  すごい大きいでしょう
当たり前なんです なぜでしょうかというと
その人は抑えた悪の方が強烈なんです
子供を殺しちゃうと もう我慢できないでしょう
ものすごい もう見ただけでも
その相手の加害者の家族みんな殺したいぐらい怒りがこみ上げてくるでしょう
だからその人が抑えた悪がすごいたくさんです
頼んだことをちょっとやってくれなかった場合の抑えた怒りがすごい小さいです
だから この相対善の大きいか小さいかということは
どれぐらい自分が抑えるのかということなんです
だから ものすごい立派な罪をするためには
心がすっごい悪が現れてこないとなんかすごい矛盾なんですよ
相対的ゾーンが善は だからすごい面白いことになります
次に行きます はい もう 1個はどれだろう
じゃあ時間もないんだからな
相対的自分の信仰に従う
死後 天を目指す まあそういう目的でもみんな善行為をしていますよ
宗教はどうであろうとも関係なく
みんな良いことをしています
それは相対的な善なんです
聖書で言ってるんだからっていうことで
いいことする 全部善行為です
あるいは死後 天を天に生まれ変わりたいとかね
成仏したいとかね まあ日本は宗教はないんだけど
まあ成仏ぐらいはしたいでしょうしね
だからその程度で悪いことをしないっていうことになる
あるいは社会のモラルを守りましょうということ
それでも善行為をする
本当はモラル守りたくないんだけど
まあ社会のモラルだから守りましょうというふうに自分を抑える
それから自分の安全幸福を考える
悪いことしちゃうとろくなことがないとわかっている
みんなに信頼されないんだと
仕事が来れないんだと
仕事はクビになるんだと
そういうことをわかって
自分の安全 自分の幸福を考えて善行為をする場合もあります
あるいは悪 悪の恐ろしさを知る
悪に怯える 世の中を見ると
人が悪を犯してなんて怖いことをやっているのか
なんで残酷なことをやっているのか
まあ怖いと言って 自分でやらないことにする
良い生き方のベネフィットを知る
また 人々はね 正しい生き方すると結構いいところありますよと
結構いい結果があります
このベネフィットを知ってやる場合もあります
悪行為は決して公平な生き方ではないと知る
悪行為っていうのは公平じゃないんですよ
例えば試験でカンニングして合格するのは公平じゃないでしょ
あの韓国でやってるような感じで
携帯で全部答えを入れてもらうと
それは公平じゃないんですよ
もう価値のない品物をものすごい嘘をいっぱい言っていて
高いお金で売ってしまう
あるいはこれだけ買ってくださいと言ってサインしてもらうんですね
それで行ったら あなたはもう十回買う契約してるんだから
今更取り消せませんよと
そうやって脅したりする
それは不公平でしょ だから悪行為はどちらにしても不公平なんです
だから公平な社会を目指す人は悪行為は嫌なんです
嘘も不公平 泥棒をすることは不公平なことでしょ
自分がせっかく頑張って苦労していたお金を誰かに取られると
これは不公平なことでしょ
だから悪行為自体が不公平であるとわかっている人々はやらない
仏教だと真理に対して理解がある
なかなかこれはもう一番下に書いてるのはなかなかない世界とか
まあこれよくある順番で書いたんです
世の中はこの善をやってますよ
世の中の人々は良いことをやっている
だからこのたくさんの人々は善行をやっている順番で下になってくると一番少ない
ブッダが教えた無常の真理
苦集滅道の真理をよくわかって
では悪をやめましょうということになるのは真っ直ぐなんです
はい 結果は相対的 善は裏で悪が支える
これは今説明した相対的善なんですけど
裏でこれ悪が支えているんですよ
なんかもう嫌なもんですよ
また悪が頻繁に善を壊す
裏にある無明とか怒りとか憎しみとかあるんだから
我々はそれを抑えてるんです
抑えることが善行為なんです
でも時々頻繁に悪が善を壊しちゃうんです
許してやりますと言ったところで
またその人が失敗しちゃうと
もう我慢できなくなっちゃうんですね
そんな感じでなっちゃうんです
自分の本能悪とそれに逆らう努力との競争ですよ
相対的善っていうのはその競争なんです
本能との競争 負けた時は悪行為
勝った時は善行為です
自分の本能に負けた瞬間で悪行為する
自分の本能に勝った瞬間で善行為している
完全な勝利も完全な敗北もない生き方です
だから我々の人生では完全な勝利もないし
完全な敗北もないんです
ということは 良いことも悪いこともしながら
ごちゃごちゃで人間は生きているんだという意味なんです
人間には誰にも完全な善はできません
完全な悪もできません
心の中の戦いであるんです
こういうことでなんか嫌な状態なんですよ
なんかいいことをするんだけど
支えてくれるのは悪だということ
はい 続き読みます 仏教的な生き方
これ仏教的な相対編です
相対善の編です 因果法則を理解する
原因に結果があるんだ
行為には必ず結果がある
結果の善し悪しは行為によって決める
冷静に考えるんですよ
心の中の悪ではなくて
行為に結果あるでしょうと
だから行為の結果の善し悪しは行為によりますよと
言うと なかなかこの裏に潜んでいる無明はあまり機能しないんですよ
これ仏教的にやると だから嫌なこの後ろめたい善にはならないんです
貪瞋痴の衝動は悪 不幸しか作らないと知る
貪瞋痴を潰すことではなくて
貪瞋痴の衝動はろくなことはしないと知っておくのです
で 不貪不瞋不痴 智慧と理性に基づいた生き方に挑戦する
だから仏教の相対善が一般相対善とはもうちょっと違うんです
一般相対善は悪に支えているんです
仏教は悪に支えないように相対善のやり方
やり方こちらで説教するんです
この人には悪があるんですけど
知ってる この貪瞋痴やと
これは これの言う話聞いちゃうとろくなことはないんだ
ことで理性と知恵に基づいて挑戦する
ブッダの真理の教えを理解して
自分の疑をなくす この疑があるんですよ
わからないっていうこと
これなくしてしまえば
やっぱり事実は事実や
例えば地球が丸いっていうことにはもう疑はないでしょ
我々誰も知らないんですよ
地球は丸いっていうこと
その計算もしていないし
宇宙に行ったわけでもないし
知らないんです しかし
疑はない そういう そういうのは
この仏教の真理を勉強すると
ああ なるほど この通りやと納得いっちゃうと
結構善はできるようになるんです
まあこのやり方でないと我々の善はちょっと後ろめたいところがあるんですよ
はい 続きましょう 悪と全くの関係ない善
それを絶対 そういう意味で絶対的な善
これが本当にできないんですよ
できないんですけど 仏教ではできます
それは悪と全く関係ない善です
悪に誘惑されされるということはありえない
あれがありえない これは無明を完全に無くすことです
無明を完全に取っ払っちゃえば
絶対的善なんです 無明をなくすということは
完全に真理に悟ることでもあります
煩悩消えた 執着がなくなった
なすべきことを成し終えた
修行を終了したなどの表現もあります
その状態になったら絶対善なんです
修行を終了したら なすべきことを成し終えたら
無明は完全になくなったら
もう絶対善なんです これが悟りの境地で
一般の生き方とは違うんです
はい それから別なタイトル
執着を断つというね だから執着を説明しましたね
欲の執着 怒りの執着と痴の執着
無知の執着 これを断って解脱しましょうというのは仏教の一般的な話なんです
しかし この何か執着を断ってください
欲を捨ててくださいと言っちゃうと
みんななんか嫌な気分になるんですよ
だからそれをちょっと説明しなくちゃいけないんです
自分が執着を断つのではありません
よく覚えてください ちょっと残酷になりますけどね
良いものも捨てるものでもったいないのでは？と思われるでしょう
執着を断ちましょうと言っちゃうと
やっぱり例えば子供に対して執着ある
執着を捨てなさいと言っても
やっぱり捨てるそういう気持ちにならんでしょう
結婚している相手に対して執着がある
捨てましょうと 執着は
やっぱりやりたくないでしょう
だから執着を断ちなさいと言った途端
あんた良いものまで捨てるというんでしょうかという気持ちが生まれるんです
自我をなくすという表現も厳密に正しくない
また 仏教でよく言いますよ
自我をなくしましょう
これも厳密に言えば正しくないんですよ
壊していいものか 壊せるのかという疑問があり得るんですからね
自我壊せますかと ずっと自分がいるという感じがあるんだから
これ死ぬことではないかとか
いろいろ疑問が出てくるんです
貪瞋痴を滅尽するなども一般的に理解しがたい
また 貪瞋痴を滅尽するということがありますけど
これもなかなか理解しにくいんです
執着とは私と私のものという 2つです
執着っていうのはどういったことない
私 私のものとの 2つです
私は五蘊によって構成されている現象なのです
私っていうのは五蘊というのは前に説明しました
色受想行識という それでできているんです
それがいつでも変わっていくんですよ
例えば自分の考え方ずっと変わっているわ
感覚はずっと変わっているわ
気持ちはずっと変わっているわ
体もずっと変わっているわ
壊れていくもので構成される
瞬時に変わるものなので
もともと私と実体として取れるものはありません
ずっと壊れて壊れて壊れていくんだから
これが私っていうものはないんですよ
川で考えてください 噴水で考えてください
これが川ですと言えますかね
ずっと変わっていくんだから
これ私というものもずっと川より早く変化しているんです
これが本来の私っていうことはないんです
大胆に言えば私がいないのです
いると思うことは錯覚
幻覚なんです だから私を執着捨てなさい
私を捨てなさいと 別に捨てるものはないんです
あれは錯覚なんです だからこの錯覚を変えなさいというだけの話
誰でも錯覚だったら嫌でしょ
幻覚だったら嫌でしょ
だからこれ錯覚 幻覚で見てなくちゃいけない
騙されているんだ そう知っちゃうと
執着捨てるっていうことはありがたいことだと分かります
まあ全般に言えば 執着捨てなさいと言えども
捨てるべき執着はありません
あの絵の佳奈えんじかな
中国でね いろいろ歌を書いてもらって
彼の先生に次の禅宗 認定するために
もう江上さんがもうただの貧しい学問ない人で
台所で仕事していただけなんです
そこでみんなもう立派な知識人で
歌を書いて 自分の悟りを表して出していて
次に誰が選ぶのかとみんな考えているんです
この人にはもう何も書けないし
この台所で誰かが書いた詩を見ている
心が鏡のごとしと それは鏡に映る塵を払うと美しく輝くという歌を書いたんです
それでみんなやっぱりこれがすごく悟りをちゃんと表現しているんだ
まあこの人ではないかと思っていたんですけど
江上さんがもともと鏡の荒らす
塵を払うってどういうこと？で書いて
それで禅僧の方がもう夜内緒でその人を呼んで
その人を次の禅師に認定して
すぐ逃げろと もう逃げ出したみたいという話があるんです
で 美想かどうかはわかりませんだけど
詩で言ってるあの詩とこの詩と比べると
当然江上さんの詩の方が理解レベルがすごい高いんです
だからもともと我はないんです
だから我を捨てろと言っても成り立たないんです
我があるというあなたの錯覚
幻覚はどうにかしなさいよという意味なんです
それで私たちもこの騙されているんだ
幻覚を起こしているんだ
理解するとこれも破りたくなりますよ
はい 次 今日は終わらないみたい
たくさんあります で 煩悩をなくすということ
なくすべき私はいないが
私とするこの 幻覚から目を覚まさなくてはならない
別になくすべき私がいるわけじゃないんです
私とする幻覚をやっぱり破らなく目覚めなくちゃいけない
私のものを一切存在しない
私のものを 私もないんだから
私のものっていうのはありえないんです
これも幻覚なんです どちらにしろか
この体 感覚 思考 感情 心
何一つも私のものと言えないんですよ
この肉体も私のものじゃないんですよ
肉体には肉体の法則があるんですよ
勝手なんです 自分の感覚も
感覚に感覚の法則がある
ずいぶん勝手なんです
自分では楽しみたいなとか
痛みは嫌だなと思っても
そうはならないんです
思考もそうでしょう もう勝手に回転してやって
自分では じゃあこういう風に考えます
こういう風に考えます
それできないんです そういうことだから
この体さえもそれぞれ勝手ですから
明らかに他人のものなの
他人っていうのおかしいんですけど
自分のものではないんです
それは因縁の法則によって勝手に生まれたり
勝手に壊れたりする 体も勝手に壊れて死んだりするわ
もうそれぞれいろんな出来事が起こると
我々はもう勝手に悩んだりするわ
自分で管理できない 面白いものを見るともう楽しくなっちゃうんですよ
管理できないんです はい
私のものと勘違いすると
余計に苦しみ 悩み 苦しみ
失望 悲しみなどが生まれるだけです
幻覚だからね 余計に苦しむんですよ
私の意思さえも 因縁によって勝手に変化していく
自分の意思さえも 例えば皆様が何か意志を持っていても他人に変えられるでしょ
気持ち変えなさいよとなんとか言っちゃうと平気で変えますから
だから自分の意思さえも自分のものでない
初めからの私のものなんかはなかったし
今もありませんし これから現れるはずもないという事実に目覚める
初めからもなかった私のものっていうのは今もないし
だからだったらこれからもない
だから仏教でのこのすごい巨大な錯覚を破りなさいというだけの話なんです
執着を捨てるのではなく
愚かさがなくなるのみ
何か大事なものを捨てる
捨てて損するんじゃないんです
自分のお腹が空かなくなるだけ
悟りという境地は 一片も損ではなくて
もう徹底した得なんです
はい 次 例えば話でいきます
中東の油田はすべて私の財産だと人が真剣に言い張っているとしましょう
我々はその人はどのように呼べるべきかと
ご存知でしょうか 例えば私でもいいんです
いきなり真剣になっちゃって
中東の油田は全部私のものよ
言うと 皆さんは私のことをどう思いますかね
まあ巨大妄想家とかね
あるいは精神錯乱者でしょ
頭がいかれているということでしょう
あんたどうかなってるんだと
しかし もし私が真剣だったら
私すごい幻覚でしょ 私は真剣
真面目に あの中東の油田は私のもの
そうすると私はあまりにもひどい幻覚に悩まされている
中東の油田に関わることについて
何一つも自分の意見は通らない
自分には何の利益もないと
あと後その人がわかることになる
中東の油田は私のものと言って言い張ってはいるんだけど
自分が言うことは聞いてくれない
ああしなさい こうしなさいとか
石油の値段下げなさい
上げなさいと言っても聞いてくれない
あのプロダクションが上げなさい
下げなさいと言っても言ってくれない
利益はあの銀行にこの銀行に入れなさいと言ったって何もやってくれないでしょう
というか 電話もつながないでしょう
それでその人が あの もしかするとあの幻覚が破れる
やっぱりいくらなんでも俺のものじゃないんだ
はい 次 私は油田の権利を放棄したと言うならば
それは嘘で笑い話 それでその人は言う
私はあの油田の権利 全部放棄しましたよ
話にならないんですね
初めから私のものではなかった
これからも私のものではないというなら正しい
中東の油田は初めから私のものではなかったし
これからも私のものではない
その錯覚はなくなっちゃってる
何か損した？その人は？損してないんですよ
しかし得をしている だって頭がいかれてたんだから
今は正常になったんだから
だから悟りというのは何も損しないんです
完全に存在に対して執着を捨てると言っても
何か捨てて損するのではない
ただ悩み苦しみが消えて楽になったのです
楽になるだけです 執着は捨てるが
捨てる執着は存在しない
ということです だから油田の話はよく覚えといてください
そうすると仏教で言う執着するという話が理解できると思います
はい それから煩悩立ってからどうなるのか
執着してからどうなるのかと
執着捨てちゃうと心には貪瞋痴は生じない
無明はないでしょ したがって一切の行為は不善にはならない
全然ただ普通にいるんだけど
何やっても不善にはならない
だって貪瞋痴がないんだから
不貪不瞋不痴を引き起こそうと努力する必要もない
貪瞋痴消えただけで まあ禅だったら不貪不瞋不痴でしょ
それはやらなくちゃ あんな苦労する必要なくなっちゃう
本能的な感情と戦って善行為をしているわけではありません
もう本能と戦う必要なくなっちゃったんです
本能そのものが死んじゃったんです
したがって 一般的な意味で善も行ってない
我々という意味では全然善をやってないんです
例えば 子供を殺した犯人を許す場合は
ものすごい怒り憎しみがあって
それを抑えたんですよ
だから善なんです この人にはそういうないもないんです
相手を抑えるべき欲が悪がないんです
だから一般的に言うと
何の善もやってないんです
これが絶対汚れない絶対的な善なのです
これが絶対汚れない善なのです
善も不善でもありません
絶対的な善は善でも不善でもないんです
はい 次に行きます 聖者という人のこと
ヨーダ プンヤンチャ パータンチョ
ウボウサンガン ウパッチャカ
アソーカンゲレジャン
シッダン タムハン ルーミ
ブラフマナ もし人は善と悪という 2つの束縛を乗り越えて
憂いなき汚れなき清浄になったならば
その人はですね 私がブッダが聖者というバラモンという
ブッダが聖者というのは
善も悪も捨てて心をきれいにした人のこと
だから善があっても心はきれいじゃないんですよ
相対的だから 悪があると綺麗じゃないってことはわかるでしょうし
しかし 善がやってるんだからといって汚れているんです
全部捨てたところで聖者なんです
これがダンマパダから
はい 次 それで知恵の見方
知恵ある人は世の中をどう見るのかと
チャックン ビック アニッチャン
ガジュニッチャン タン
ドゥッカン ジャン ドゥッカン
タダ ナッタ ヤダ ナッタ
タン メー タン ママ メー
ソーハマス ナ メー ソワッタティ
エワン メー タン ヤタ ブータン
サッマ パンニャー ダッタ
バン 比丘たちよ 目は無常です
無常たるものは苦です
苦たるものは無我なのです
無我たるものは無我たるものは私のものでもない
私でもない 私の魂でもない
と如実に正しい智慧で見るべきです
あの前に来たセットですよ
私のもの 私 私の魂 それは目に対してそういうことで
他のものに対しても同じことを言います
はい 次 この見方 方程式を目チャック
耳ソータ 鼻ガーナ 舌ジウハ
体カーヤ 意 意識のことマナという内の認識器官 6つにも外の対象である色ルーパ
色っていうのは目に入るもの
声というのは耳に入るもの
それで鼻に入るもの 身っていうのは舌に入るもの
触っていうのは体に触れるもの
法っていうのは心で考えるもの
その 6つにも入ります
同じ方程式 私ではありません
私のものではありません
私の魂でもありません 12
あります 全部 それから過去アティータ
未来アナガタ 現在パッチュッパンナという 3世にも適用します
過去の目も私のものではない
今の目も私のものではない
これから現れる目も私のものではないという
に観察するんです これを悟る
悟る時のやり方なんです
いわゆる修行中の方々が修行をいくらか達成して悟る段階に入ると
こういう風な瞑想をするんです
それで私はこの過去未来現在と書いているんですよ
普通は過去現在未来でしょ
仏教ではこの順番なんです
どちらにしても仏教はすごい微妙なんですよ
過去現在っていうのは存在しないものなんです
だから存在しないものを一緒にして
存在する今の瞬間が存在する
それは修行にすると 我々の考え方は過去現在未来だからね
はい それからその経典の続き
エーワンパッサンビッカヴェー スタワーアリアサーロコ チャックスミンティ ニッビン
ガティ ニッビンダン ヴィラッジャティ ヴィラーガー ヴィムッジャティ ヴィムッタスミン ヴィムッタンティ ニャーナン
ホーティ ヒーナージャーティ ウシタンブラフマチャリャン カタンカラニーニャン ナーカラン イッタッターヤーティ パジャーナーティ
このように見る智慧のある仏弟子は目にも飽きる
そこから転々転々全部入ります
耳やら鼻やらもう全部意識までそちらでも飽きる
飽きるから解脱する それから解脱をしたという智慧が生じる
生生まれることが滅した
修行は終えた なすべきことは成し終えた
これからこの世に戻ることはないと知る
もう終わったと 随分ホッとするんです
それが絶対善のやり方なんです
じゃあ早く進む まあこれからは難しくないんで
ただ経典だと思います
そこで無知の旗は不道徳
無知な人は不道徳という旗を立てて生きているんです
プッターマッティ ダナンマッティ イティ バアロー イハンジャティ アッターヒ アッテノーナッティ プトープッター プトーダナン
私に子孫がいる 財産があると愚か者が悩む
自分さえも自分のものではありません
何の子孫 何の財産か というダンマパダの
あなたにあなたもないのに
俺には子供がいる 何言ってるんでしょうか
そんなことで罪を犯しちゃいますからね
はい 次 チャランティバアラ ドゥンメーラ アミッテーネーワ アッタナ カロンターパーパカン カンマン ヤンホーティ カトゥカッパラ
智慧のない愚か者が自分自身の敵のように生きる
だから智慧のない人が自分の敵なんですよ
なぜかというと 厳しい不幸を招く悪行為を行いつつ
厳しい不幸を招く悪行為を行いつつ生きているんだから
だからバカな人は悪いことばっかりやっていますから
選挙でも ければ不賄賂でも何でもやる
嘘は言いたい放題言う
良かったんじゃないか
まだ言われる 地獄に落ちる罪を犯してるんだから
あのバカが だからもう自分愚かさっていうのは自分が自分の敵になるっていうことである
はい 次 ヤーワデーワナッタエニャッタンバーラッサジャーヤティタンビバーラッサスッカッサムッダマッサイバータヤ
無知な人は何かを知ったとしても
それもまた なんでしょうかね
自分ですね 自分の不幸を招く
彼の彼のわずかな良いところもなくなって
完全に破壊に陥る この愚か者のやり方
まあ無知な人が何か知ったとしましょう
例えば無知な人が仏教を勉強したっても
とんでもない罪を犯しちゃうんですよ
例えば我がないんだから
全部無常だから どうせあんた死ぬんだから
あなたの業から見ると
私から殺される運命だと
と言って人を殺すこともできますよ
だから仏教を知ったのはまだ危険ですよ
無知な人は 例えば科学者とかいるでしょう
大量破壊兵器を作る 原子爆弾を作る
それでちょっと勉強できたことはいいことなんですけど
それによって地獄に落ちちゃう
だからまあ 知恵のない人は何かもう知恵のない
まあ子供に包丁をあげることと同じなんですよ
アメリカなんか子供がピストルで遊んじゃうでしょう
撃ってみるんですよ 誰か誰か
そんなもんなんです はい
それから無知な人のまたあります
カンマダッコノビッカラバーロカンマダッコノパンビトアパダーナソーヴィニパンニャ
このアパダーナソーヴィニパンニャっていうのはブッダの名言としてよく
使っている言葉ひとつなんです
愚か者は行いで理解できる
智者も行いで理解できる
智慧が人格を輝かせるという
智慧があるんだったら人格者なんですよ
頭がいいかどうか 自分の性格でわかるんですよ
そういうことなんです
だから性格が良い人は頭がいいんです
頭が良くても性格が悪い人
世界でいっぱいいるでしょうに
勉強はできるんだけど
科学者なんですけど ちょっと性格が荒い人いる
そういうのは愚か者なんです
危ないんです ティヒビッカラダンメーサマンナーガトバーロウェーダトカトゥメイティカーイビッタリクナワチービッタリクナマノジッタリク
3つのことで愚か者を発見できる
3つとは 体で悪行為をする
言葉で悪行為をする 心で悪行為をする
愚か者っていうのは悪行為ばっかりする
だから我々も悪いことしちゃうと当然愚か者なんです
はい 次 まあ早くやります
愚か者が競争すること
財産を得ること 権力名誉を得ることを胸を張って自慢する
結果が良ければ手段はどうでも良いのではないかと思う
世の中みんなそういうことでしょうに
知識を金儲かろう もっと美しくなろう
痩せてやろうとかそんな話ばっかりです
しわがなくなるようにもあらゆる化粧
お化粧しようとかね そんなものばっかしで生きてて自慢もする
悪はたとえ本能であっても
本能のままで生きること
罪を犯して生きることは
世に自分は相当な愚か者であると宣言することです
だから悪は本能ですよ
つい人が悪いことする
しかし そんなことに乗っちゃって悪いことすると自分で宣言しています
私が馬鹿者や馬鹿者やと
私は自分の敵であると
ということを言っていることなんですね
私は頑張って不幸になるのだということです
どういったことか 私はよく頑張ってますと
不幸になるために まあどうせ本来人間不幸だから頑張らなくてもいいのに
愚か者は財産得るためにあれしてこれで頑張って
さらに不幸になって地獄に落ちちゃうんだっていうこと
はい 次 智者の道  それで終わります
目の前の誘惑には負けない
心の叫びに耳を傾けない
心の叫びというのは悪の叫びなんです
本能に感情に負けない
金よりも何よりも人格は大事だとする
他人とではなく 自分と戦う
理性によって行動する
善の生き方 罪を犯すな生き方こそが
この世でもあの世でも勝利の道だと知る
だから善の生き方 この世でも勝利しますよ
俗世間に出ても良い人が結構安全にして生きてやれます
アメリカの大統領にならないかもしれませんだけど
誰にも批判されないで
すごい落ち着いては生活します
そういうことで あの善と悪っていうのは
まあこういう戦いがあるんだという話です
で これで悪に なんて言いますか
悪 悪に支えている線がありまして
善とそういう2つが戦っている
その問題解決する仏教の絶対的善の道もあるんです
ということで話は終了です
今日はゴチャゴチャしゃべらなくちゃいけないんだから
今日は新聞として大物だったんです
[笑い]